ich begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
heute kommen wir zum ersten mal auf ein
modell gegenwärtigen text zu sprechen
wir hatten ja die letzten sitzung sehr
viel historische texte behandelt wir
werden auch in der heutigen sitzung
nochmals historischen text behandeln
müssen einfach deswegen weil wir sonst
nicht vollständig sind gut
vollständigkeit wird man nie richtig
erziehen können aber wir würden einen
ganz wichtigen denker dieser debatte
vernachlässigen und zwar können sie sich
denken wäre es ist das ist autor
schopenhauer hatte schopenhauer hat auch
interessante beiträge zu dieser frage
geleistet und wir werden uns fragen
worin sich tiere von menschen nach
schopenhauer unterscheiden und auch
diese auffassung von schopenhauer um die
überzeugend ist das ist unsere fragen
und wir werden dann am ende oder besser
gesagt eine zweite sitzung der zweiten
hälfte der sitzung noch auf einen
gegenwärtigen denker eingehen der ein
beitrag geschrieben hat den sie in
dieser suhrkamp textausgabe finden
genau und jetzt gehen wir einfach mal
mit den text hinein ich lese mal vor aus
dem besagten sagt jetzt shoppen habe
ergibt sich dass alle tiere verstand
haben selbst die unvollkommen zum 10
da muss fehlt an wert denn dort sehen
sie alle erkennen objekte und diese
erkenntnis bestimmt als motiv in ihre
bewegungen der verstand ist sind allen
tieren und allen menschen der nämlich
hat überall dieselbe einfache form die
kenntnis der kausalität übergang von
wirkung auf ursache und verursache auf
wilke und nichts außer dem aber die
gerade seiner schärfe und die ausdehnung
seiner erkenntnis wäre sind höchst
verschieden mannigfaltig und vielfach
abgestuft vom niedrigsten grad welche
nur das kausalität verhältnis zwischen
dem unmittelbaren objekt und den
unmittelbaren
erkennt und eben hinreicht durch den
übergang von der einwirkung welche der
leib erleidet auf deren ursache diese
als objekt im raum anzuschauen
bis zu den höheren graden der erkenntnis
des kausalen zusammenhangs der bloß
mittelbaren objekte untereinander welche
bis zum verstehen der zusammengesetzten
verkettung von ursachen und wirkung in
der natur geht denn auch dieses letztere
gehört immer noch zu den verstande an
nicht der vernunft deren abstrakte
begriffe nur dienen können jenes
unmittelbar verstandene aufzunehmen zu
fixieren und zu verknüpfen nie das
verstehen selbst hervorzubringen so
jetzt kommen hier ein paar wichtige
begriffe ins spiel
verstand und vernunft das müssen wir uns
jetzt mal genauer anschauen
also häufig verwendet man ja in der
geschichte der philosophie verstand und
vernunft fast schon zu nun auf der
straße wenn man da jemand fragt sagen
sie mir mal was ist der unterschied
zwischen verstand und vernunft werden
die meisten menschen sagen kopf
gesprungen
ich kenne da keinen unterschied
es sind alles form von rationale
vermögen sind ist wir können damit
denken da sind die vermögen die uns in
die lage setzen zu denken
und vielleicht logisch zu denken
vernünftig zu denken jetzt haben wir
dann schnell die vernunft drin
die meisten menschen werden sagen es
gibt keinen unterschied ein ganz
wichtiger denkt hat der zwischen
vernunft und verstand unterschieden hat
ist klar tonnen zunächst einmal
plattform hat die an neujahr schreibe
ich auch noch mal hin
und den muss unterschieden
also los hatte ich glaube ich auch mal
in diesem seminar gesagt oder den antrag
ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher
news hängt mit dem deutschen wort von
unten zusammen also das deutsche wort
vernunft und deckt das griechische wort
muss die sind geologisch verwandt
miteinander
durch dieses - das ist mit diesem von
uns
das ist platt von platon sagt die diana
ist das vermögen was uns in die lage
versetzt das beispiel mathematische
operationen durchzuführen
das ist die dialoge oder vergleiche
anzustellen begriffliches denken
begriffs verhältnisse zu denken das ist
dieses rechnerische denken in seinem
sinne der mathematik so vielleicht am
besten da kommt die diana ins spiel
der verstand und die den news die von
null ist das vermögen was uns die ideen
erkennen lässt mit dem wir letztendlich
zu den letzten bildern vortrag
deswegen sagt auch platon der die diana
ist mittelbar die geht immer
schrittweise vor
man könnte auch sagen so eine art von
instrumenteller vernunft mittels weg
relation das ist das denken des
verstandes während die vernunft
unmittelbar ist sofort die einsicht hat
in die ideen die ideen sind somit über
vorhanden wir kennen sie unmittelbar als
einheit punkte könnte man sagen
während in auf der ebene der diana immer
die verhältnisse rolle spielen
begriffliche verhältnisse
und es ist klar dass im sinne dieser
verhältnisse dass diese verhältnis
relation sich in der welt zeigt mit
blick auf die kausalität wenn wir von
ursache wirkung sprechen
das ist ein verhältnis wenn wir immer
schauen wollen was war die ursache
was war die wirkung was war die ursache
zu dieser wirkung was war die wirkung
auf diese ursache dann sagt würde
sicherlich von sagen und fielen nach ihm
auch dann bis hier der verstand zugang
die vernunft hat es nicht so mit diesen
relationen zu tun sondern eher mit
diesen in diesen stand an erkenntnissen
der einheit
es gibt es noch einen anderen großen
philosophen der ein bisschen später
gelebt hat der auch diese unterscheidung
ist er stark gemacht hat wissen sie alle
das war immanuel kant und auch er knüpft
könnte man sagen an diese platonische
unterscheidung er sagt der verstand ist
jetzt wenn sich das vermögen
unter anderem die kausalität kennen in
der bild es ist nicht nur die erkenntnis
der kausalität sondern überhaupt die
bedingungen der kausalität die bedingung
der möglichkeit von kausalität dass es
der verstand wir brauchen wir jetzt
nicht mehr mit ein er darauf eingehen
wichtig ist nur dass wenn es um
qualitäts verhältnisse geht dann der
verstand nach kann jetzt ganz zentrale
rolle spielt oder wenn es um
instrumentelle vernunft geht mittel
zweck relation und so weiter zu fahren
dann ist der verstand dort zugange die
vernunft ganz ähnlich wie bei platon
auch die vernunft ist nach kant
dasjenige was absolutes denkt mich immer
nur relatives mittels weg relation
kausalität sondern was die erste ursache
von allem denkt als nicht nur irgendeine
ursache irgendeine wirkung der welt und
da wieder die wirkung und so weiter und
so fort sondern die erste ursache allen
existierenden dass das denkt die
vernunft
also könnte sagen dass absolute
das erste anfang
hier ist der anfang und so weiter und so
fort
also das hörvermögen könnte man die
vernunft die transzendiert nochmal den
verstand ich sollte eigentlich die
vernunft über den verstand schreiben
also die vernunft frage nach der
allerersten ursache all dessen was jetzt
existiert nicht nur irgendeine ursachen
das ist so die diese dimension die ist
ganz ähnlich bei platon und dies auch
bei kann so und jetzt
wenn jetzt schopenhauer hier verstanden
vernunft verbindet dann ist es liegt es
auf der hand dass schopenhauer hier an
kanten das altersheim begriff von
verstand und vernunft dem kantischen
entsprechen jetzt sagte in zeile 3
der verstand ist in allen tieren und
allen menschen der nämlich hat über all
diese einfache form erkenntnis der
kausalität übergang von wirkung auf
ursachen und verursacher erwirken und
nichts außerdem das ist jetzt ein
bisschen problematisch interpretation
von kant weil bei kant ist es so erkannt
hat der verstand noch eine bedeutung mit
blick auf andere begriffe nicht nur auf
kausalität sondern auch noch mit blick
auf substantially tät also dass die
substanz blick auf relation blick auf
modernität die ganzen aristotelischen
kategorien die nicht nur kausalität sind
die komplett bringt den verstand hinein
aber die kausalität relation ist aber
mal die wichtigste relation die den
verstand
bedanken kann sich jetzt ganz einfach
einfach vorstellen der verstand erkennt
kausalität verhältnisse in der welt
jetzt sagt hier schopenhauer und wie mir
scheint in einer gewissen nähe so david
hume wir hatten in der letzten sitzung
auch david hume gelesen man sich noch
bei der video die vernunft oder
verstanden ist das klare der effekte es
war die these von der video und es war
der grund weshalb die auffassung
vertreten hatte dass tiere und menschen
letztendlich ziemlich ähnlich sind bei
ihnen immer nur die antriebe des
entscheides sind und ein mal eben der
instinkt beim tier diesen antrieben
genüge tut diesen antrieben nachkommen
und bei menschen die vernunft und dann
sagt jun
natur instinkt unvernunft sind im grunde
dasselbe ich vernünftig ist letztendlich
der menschlichen natur institut anhöre
natur instinkt des menschens aktion
insofern sind tiere und menschen
ziemlich ähnlich fast ihre erzählt
anbelangt
schon aber man findet ja schon auch
differenzen aber entscheidend ist für
die rationalität ist dieser gedanke des
verstandes also kausalität erkenntnis
schlüsse das vermögen zu schließen
im sinne von ursache wirkung das ist für
jung darin erschöpft sich eigentlich hat
sanität ja es gibt noch was anderes als
ich ihm gesagt relations auf heidi es
ist auch noch ein vermögen des
verstandes also begriffe miteinander zu
vergleichen
das sagen zu sagen dieser begriff
widerspricht diesen begriff oder dieser
begriff ist identisch mit diesem begriff
das ist auch noch eine operation des
verstandes oder der vernunft das hat
dann nichts mehr mit kausalität zu tun
das hat nichts mehr mit ihrem piri zu
tun aber da sagt yu na gut begriffe
miteinander zu vergleichen das ist schon
gut aber das bringt uns im leben ist
nichts konkret was uns zu überleben
hilft ist letztendlich kausalitäten zu
entdecken und kausalität studie zeigt
dass war die ursache davon
und wenn ich die ursache als solche
erkannt habe dann habe ich davon auch in
lebenspraktischen nutzen und im sinne
dieser lebenspraxis kann jung sagen sind
sich mensch und hier ziemlich ähnlich
könnte also sagen jugend bestreitet dass
es so eine form von vernunft gibt die
relevant ist das absolute erst anfangen
zu denken
das ist auch der grund weshalb der
mensch und tier sehen einander bringt
sagt schopenhauer wie mir scheint sehr
ähnlich auf der linie von human dass der
verstand bei tieren und menschen
derselbe ist nämlich die kausalität
betrifft aber die gerade seine schärfe
und die ausdehnung seiner erkenntnis
wäre sind höchst verschieden
mannigfaltig und vielfach abgestuft vom
niedrigsten gerade welche nur das kausal
verhältnis zwischen dem unmittelbaren
objekt unmittelbaren er kennt also eben
hinreicht durch den übergang von der
einwirkung welche den leib erleidet auf
deren ursache diese als objekt den raum
anzuschauen das wäre vielleicht so
einfach ist ein kleines insekt ein
kleines insekt das wenn man das mal
antippt wenn man ihm seinen kleinen stoß
verleiht dann merkt dass hoppla hier
gibt es außerhalb im raum so eine
einwirkung auf mich und deswegen fliegt
davon so stelle ich mir das vor das wäre
der niedrigste gratis kausalität
verhältnis ist ne unmittelbare physische
einwirkung
bis zu den höheren graden der kenntnis
des kausalen zusammenhangs der bloßen
mittelbaren objekte untereinander welche
bis zum verstehen der zusammengesetzt
eine verkettung von ursache und wirkung
in der natur geht also es ist
letztendlich nach schopenhauer nur ein
gradueller verhältnis eine graduelle
differenz zwischen dem menschlichen
verstandenem tierischen verstand der
tierische verstand den kausalität in
engeren bereichen mittelbarer also
die unmittelbare muss man seine
unmittelbare also hier ist eine
einwirkung und hier ist die wirkung
hier ist die ursache ist die wirkung in
solchen kurzen kausalität skaten könnte
man sagen denken nach schopenhauer das
tier hier wäre dann den adern b ursache
wirkungs nur so um beim menschen ist es
so
beim menschen ist es halt so da gibt es
halt mehr regt liter und ich kann jetzt
praktisch von hier zurückspringen und
hier auf a zurück sprecher während das
tier immer nur in solchen kurzen ketten
dem kurzkettige kausal verhältnisse und
man kann diese ketten beliebig lang
machen und sagen je höher die
rationalität ist desto länger die ketten
desto länger kann dieses kausal
verhältnis zurückverfolgt wird
würden sie meinen deputation zustimmen
denkt das so schönborn
das
der verstand und bewusstsein verbund
das zeigt dass das los
ich weiß es nicht
die frage muss bewusstsein vorhanden
sein um verständigte
und denen der haupt- und so verstanden
dass sie keinen bestand
das ist das schöne
und
die thesen im 500
durch die entschieden sagt rauch
da war noch eine menge unternehmen
trixi als er lässt verschiedene geradezu
je nach sage ich mal als kausalität
kette und die frage wäre dann halt auch
noch die nach dem bewusstsein muster
bewusstsein davon vorhanden sein das war
doch so ihre frage jetzt aber ich denke
dass man sagen könnte auch auf der ebene
von fast schon instinktiven handlungen
instinktiven reaktionen das ist so eine
art von verinnerlicht dem verstand gibt
das also dieses qualitätsdenken fast
schon instinktiv und intuitiv abläuft
dass der verstand sich in uns
eingeschrieben hat wir sind dieser
konditionierung also wenn häufig diese
verhältnisse stattgefunden haben immer
wenn a und b also das war ja das
beispiel was wir schon vor allen dingen
sitzung gelesen haben der hund frisst
fleisch aus dem topf und dann bekommt er
ärger vom herrchen wenn er das häufig
genug gemacht hat dann könnte man sagen
sagt jedenfalls der philosoph des
beispiels ist dann hat sich der verstand
eingeschrieben in die natur des tieres
und dann würde keine reflexion der unter
umständen stattfinden müssen also ich
denke nicht dass unbedingt verstand mit
selbstbewusstsein einhergehen muss in
basalen formen glaube ich nicht oder
bewusst sein
die karten haben
das ist ja keinen verstand es gibt
ja also häufig ist es so man die
freiheit wie viel wird dann noch gedacht
aktiv wie viele operationen des
verstandes ist noch da man würde ja
sagen sich ich kontrolliere ist gar
nicht mehr es ist passiert so ich halt
ich greife schnell hinzu das wäre jetzt
auch nicht so dieser typische fall von
kausalität denken also denke ich bin so
ein glas umfeld es eine reaktion auf das
umfallen des glases wir wollen
verhindern dass das glas zu bruch geht
ich glaube hier geht es jetzt eben
solche fälle wo ursachen und wirkungen
die rolle spielen also die ursache ist
das fressen aus diesem topf und die
wirkung ist letztendlich die strafe
durch das herrschen
es geht der kausalität immer um den
übergang verursachen wirkung eine
entität oder ein ereignis wird als
ursache interpretiertes andere als
wirkung
und ich glaube durchaus dass wir
kausalität strukturen verinnerlichen
können wir so einen vernünftigen
verinnerlichen können ohne dass es uns
wirklich ganz bewusst vor augen steht
muss weil es sich für innerlich tat
könnte das jetzt konditionierung nennen
vielleicht können sagt konditionierung
ist der verstand der uns zur natur
geworden ist mein verstand des
verhältnis 1 1 kasal verhältnis was ich
in unsere natur eingeschrieben hat so
dass wir darüber gar nicht mehr
reflektieren müssen
das geht natürlich bei solchen
kurzkettigen kausal verhältnissen zu
erleiden
aber eine konditionierung über vier
glieder von ursachen wirkungen weg 1234
das ist schwieriger desto zu
verinnerlichen weil der reichen einfach
unsere gewohnheit nicht mehr hin um rück
zu schließen also wenn es besonders
viele solche rückschlüsse bedarf also
was war davon die ursache war es von
warten was wollen wir von dieser ursache
die ursache usw
ich glaube da muss dann bewusstsein ins
spiel kommen da kann so eine
konditionierung nicht mehr stattfinden
da müssen wir ganz bewusst darüber denkt
und das ist dann nicht mehr automatisch
habe ich denke letztendlich ist es ein
gradueller quantitativer prozess der
sich durch das ganze tierreich zeit
kontinuum könnte man sagen
aktuell ist continum war es jetzt den
verstand
er sagte nämlich unten
auch diese letzteren gehört immer noch
den verstand
also die zusammengesetzten verkettung
dieses letzterer gehört auch
einverstanden nicht der vernunft deren
abstrakte begriffe nur dienen können
jenes unmittelbar verstandene
aufzunehmen zu verzieren zu fixieren und
zu verknüpfen
die das verstehen selbst hervorzubringen
wir müssen jetzt mal weiter lesen und
schauen wie schopenhauer die vernunft
und verstand abgrenzt ob die vernunft
als vermögen nur dem menschen
vorbehalten ist oder auch den tieren
er sagt weiter jede naturkraft und jedes
naturgesetz jeder fallen welchem sie
sich äußern muss zunächst vom verstande
unmittelbar erkannt intuitiv aufgefasst
werden ehe er in abstrakter für die
vernunft ins reflektierte bewusstsein
treten kann intuitiv für unmittelbare
auffassung durch den verstand
robert fuchs entdeckung das
gravitationsgesetz
und die zurückführung so viele und große
erscheinungen auf dies einiges ließ
sodann newtons berechnungen zu bewerten
eben das war auch labors entdeckung des
sauerstoffs und seiner wichtigen rolle
in der natur gebe dass goethes
entdeckung der entstehungsort physischer
fahren
diese entdeckungen alles alles sind
nichts anderes als ein richtiges
unmittelbares zurückgehen von der
wirkung auf die ursache werde alsbald
die erkenntnis der identität der in
allen ursachen der selben art
präsentiert und diese gesamte einzig ist
eine bloß dem gerade nach verschiedene
äußerungen der nämlichen und einzigen
funktion des verstandes durch welche
auch ein tier die ursache welche auf
seinen live wirkt als objekt im raum
anschaut
daher sind auch jene großen entdeckungen
alle eben wie die anschauung und jedes
für jede verstandes äußerung eine
unmittelbare einsicht und als solche das
werk des augenblicks seiner person ein
einfall nicht das produkt langer schluss
ketten in abstrakter welche letzte
hingegen dienen die unmittelbare
verstandes erkenntnis für die vernunft
durch niederlegung in ihrer abstrakten
begriffe zu fixieren das heißt so
deutlich zu machen das heißt sich in den
stand zu setzen sie anderen zu deuten zu
bedeuten
jene schärfe des verstandes dem auf
passende kausal beziehungen und dann
geht es weiter
wo man bis dahin nur das sagte jetzt
hier
wie war es jetzt mit youtube
das hat ihn gemacht
der sache nicht
und er sagt jetzt aber sein
unmittelbares zurückgehen von der
wirkung auf die ursachen also ein
schluss praktisch auf den letzten kunden
das warum
aber so
dass er leiten zu können
und jetzt ist die frage ist diese
vernunft ist das jetzt eine verstandes
tätigkeit
es ist nicht verstanden das kind nach
schopenhauer schonen
heute ist jetzt ob das wie das jetzt mit
der vernunft zu sammeln
er führt die rallye an dass sie
letztendlich eine eine verstandes
tätigkeit haus geführt hat er sagt jede
naturkräften jedes natur gesetzt jeder
fall in welchem sie sich äußern muss
zunächst vom verstand er unmittelbar
kann intuitiv aufgefasst werden ehe er
in abstrakte für die vernunft ins
reflektierte bewusstsein treten kann
jetzt geht es also darum jetzt muss
praktisch an übergang stattfinden von
verstand und vernunft und was zeigt
jetzt hier nach oben die vernunft aus
das sagte hier oben
das sagt dr
in abstrakter
also es muss irgendwie abstrakt sei
abstrakt einfallen kranken die frage wie
jetzt hier aber das ist jetzt für die
frage nach dem tier nicht so wichtig ist
dann die formel die jetzt da dann
berechnet wurde
die ist ja schon ziemlich abstrakt ist
die formel deine sache der vernunft
die einzige die diese großen denker
haben
das scheint mir auch so verstanden
unmittelbar erkannt intuitiv aufgefasst
werden g1 traktor für die vernunft ins
reflektierte mustern treten kann
also nehme jetzt eben sagt von
verstanden unmittelbar erkannt intuitiv
aufgefasst werden ist ja eigentlich nach
der platonischen tradition er am
nächsten
also das ist ein bisschen schwierig
jetzt die vernunft ist ja eigentlich das
was unmittelbar auf fast den verstand
ist ja immer das was mittelbar denkt in
diesen ketten
offensichtlich sagte das jetzt hier
trotzdem ist eigentlich als ich mein man
könnte sagen intuitiv ist jetzt hier die
rückführung der wirkung auf die ursache
so was kann natürlich auch intuitiv
seien aber schwierig wird seien bei
solchen viergliedrigen konstellation
intuitiv von dfa zu schließen
das ist sehr schwierig denn was man
machen könnte man könnte hier sagen
gut.de zu kommen muss ich sowas
postulieren
so was muss ich muss ich erst ein grund
fordert nach kant wäre das sein erster
grund zu fordern
die eine sache der vernunft und des
verstandes hatte scheint jetzt bei
schopenhauer schon eine gewisse
differenz aufzutun zu kant
und jetzt kommt er drüber schauen also
welche rolle spielt jetzt hier die
vernunft sagt er hier dieses neue höhe
potenzierte bewusstsein
diese abstrakte reflex alles intuitiven
im nicht anschaulichen begriffene
vernunft ist es allein der den menschen
jene besonnenheit von leid welches sein
bewusstsein von dem investieren so
durchaus unterscheidet und wodurch sein
ganzer wandel auf erden zu verschieden
ausfällt an dem seine unvernünftigen
brüder aha also jetzt geht's um die
entscheidende differenz zwischen
menschen tiere und die betrifft jetzt
die vernunft nicht einverstanden
gleich sehr übertrifft erzieherin macht
und dann bleiben sie leben in der
gegenwart allein seine brüder auch
interessant wir von den tieren spricht
dessen die brüder gleich selber tritt er
macht kleiden sie leben in der gegenwart
allein er der mensch dabei zugleich in
zukunft und vergangenheit sie
befriedigen das augenblickliche
bedürfnis er sorgt durch die künstlich
ssten anstalten für seine zukunft dafür
zeiten die er nicht erleben kann
sie sind dem eindruck des augenblicks
der wirkung des anschaulichen motivs
gänzlich anheim gefallen ihnen der
stimmen abstrakte begriffe unabhängig
von der gegenwart
daher führt er überlegte pläne aus oder
handelt nach maximen ohne rücksicht auf
die umgebung und die zufälligen
eindrücke des augenblicks äckern daher
zb mit gelassenheit die künstlichen
anstalten seinen eigenen tode treffen
kann sich verstehen bis zur unerforscht
lichkeit und sein geheimnis mit ins grab
nehmen hat endlich eine wirkliche wahl
zwischen mehreren motiven
denn nur in abstrakte können solche
nebeneinander im bewusstsein gegenwärtig
die erkenntnis
bei sich führen dass eines das andere
ausschließt und so ihre gewalt über den
willen gegeneinander messen wonach dann
das überwiegend in dem es den ausschlag
gibt überlegte entscheidung des willens
ist und als ein sicheres anzeichen seine
beschaffenheit kunden an
jetzt das ist jetzt hier den die
zentrale stelle hier geht es jetzt um
die differenz zwischen mensch und tier
ist auffällig dass in zeile 5 sagt die
tiere sind die unvernünftigen brüder
dass menschen
damit ist jetzt nicht gemeint dass tiere
keine rationalität hand tiere haben
verstand also mit blick auf den verstand
unterscheiden sie sich graduell so dass
sie eben nicht so lange schluss ketten
bilden können aber da ist es
letztendlich nur sache des grades der
quantität und jetzt müssen wir mal
genauer herausarbeiten was jetzt das
entscheidet der vernunft ist das muss
als ein höheres bewusstsein sein etwas
was abstrakt ist und was nicht
anschaulich ist nicht anschaut was
zutrifft nicht anschauen ich haben sie
da eine idee was ist jetzt nicht
anschaulich bande von unten im gegensatz
zum verstand
was könnte jetzt an der vernunft nicht
anschaulich sein was könnte da ein jetzt
abstrakt zahlen an vernunft überlegungen
zeitlich überlegungen
wir verdammen
zum beispiel zukunftsangst dass ich
jetzt sagen wir angst haben wie es in
zehn jahren ist so einmalig betrachtet
die das landespokal verhältnissen also
ich betrachte jetzt die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung angenommen einem bestimmten
land und mache mir jetzt sorgen wie sind
zehn jahren um mich steht da ist gar
kein konkretes objekt jetzt in der welt
was auf mich einfluss übt was mich
konkret bedroht die wirtschaftliche lage
könnte sogar sehr gut sein
dennoch macht man sich ein begriff der
ziemlich abstrakt ist er ist deswegen
abstrakt weil er nicht in der gegenwart
ist also ist eine andere zeit sphäre wir
sind zukunft und er ist deswegen
abstrakt weil er gar nicht konkret von
einem leiden ausgeht
es könnte ja der wirtschaft sehr gut
gehen die wirtschaftsweisen sagen in
zehn jahren ist die wirtschaftslage in
deutschland katastrophal
es gibt jetzt eine große inflation oder
was ich aber noch ist es
die würde schopenhauer sagen ein tier
würde gehen diesen unmittelbaren
umständen hof gehen
es hat kein bewusstsein von
vergangenheit und zukunft
es kann sich keine abstrakte vorstellung
machen das wäre vielleicht ein beispiel
zukunftsangst aufgrund von
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung ist meine
prognose macht prognose hatte etwas sehr
abstraktes ist ein zukunfts begriff
reduktion
das wäre vielleicht dachten es wäre
nicht mehr der eindruck des augenblicks
der bestimmt nach schopenhauer die tiere
natürlich kann man jetzt sich das frage
ob das stimmt ob es nicht doch irgendwie
bei kränen oder sonstigen tieren solche
antizipation ischen momente gibt denke
schon dass es die gibt bei krähen weil
die er durchaus und die zukunft auch ein
bisschen denken wenn sie jetzt die
instrumente bauen in dem sich
instrumente bauen antizipieren sie ja
auch ganz kurze frist in die zeit
also wenn ich das so macht und dann das
so macht dann müsste das klar das ist ja
so die überlegung bei creme letztendlich
also ich denke auch in dem man sich ein
werkzeug herstellt könnte man vielleicht
so etwas wie abstrakte begriff der
vernunft in ansätzen sich finden oder
würze
zu den absätzen
das handy ist insolvent
ok
gut okay sie sagen als selbst bei der
grill ist das ganze setting immer noch
im gegenwärtigen moment anzusiedeln oder
nicht irgendwie abstrakt jetzt in
zukunft ja
das ist einfach anders aussehen also das
zu klären 30 jahren zu finden aber dafür
reinigen
anders als es 16
allerdings verbrauchen
das ist ein
[Musik]
also man könnte sich jetzt fragen ist
nicht der unterschied zwischen vernunft
und verstand auch ein gradueller also
kommt die vernunft dann ins spiel wenn
wenn zeitlichkeit ins spiel kommt zeit
und abstraktion
schopenhauer scheint davon auszugehen
dass ist nicht aktuell zurück
ja richtig also offensichtlich ja also
wie gesagt ich möchte darauf hinweisen
zeile fünf brüder unvernünftige brüder
wenn man das nur so liest würde man
denken er spricht den tieren die
rationalität abt oder nicht gesteht in
den verstand zu haben niederen grad und
er sagt auch brüder also es ist
irgendwie auf derselben ebene und jetzt
wenn sie mal genau lesen ist eigentlich
so dass der mensch immer noch die
bemitleidenswerte bruder ist weil er
leidet da fiel mir die vernunft bringt
den menschen ja letztendlich nur leid
warum weil der mensch übertrifft sie die
tiere die brüder die weniger vernünftig
oder nicht vernünftigen genaugenommen
brüder an macht und an leiden die ihr
leben der gegenwart sie haben also keine
zukunftsangst und können auch nichts
bereuen der vergangenheit
sie leben jetzt endlich im augenblick
selbst sehen sie befriedigend oder eben
auch nicht mehr
ja also ich glaube hier kommt zu dieser
pessimismus ein bisschen spiel also
diese vernunft ist zweischneidig
sie bringt den menschen sehr viel leid
durch ihre zukunftsplanung durch die
zukunftsangst nur das tier hingegen
bestimmte gegenwärtige eindruck nur die
furcht vor dem gegenwärtigen zwang an
seine begierde 10 bis jene furcht
endlich zur gewohnheit geworden ist und
nunmehr als solches bestimmen das ist
ressort das tier empfindet und schaut an
der mensch denkt über diese weise beide
wollen das tier teilt seine empfindung
und stimmung mit durch gebärde und laut
der mensch teilt dem anderen gedanken
mit der sprache oder verbirgt gedanken
durch sprache sprache ist das erste
erzeugnis und das notwendige werkzeug
seiner vernunft
daher wird im griechischen und
italienischen der italienischen sprache
und vernunft durch dasselbe wort
bezeichnet logos bild des corso vernunft
kommt vom vernehmen welches nicht zu
ende ist wird hören sondern dass ihnen
werden der ich wurde mitgeteilt gedanke
bedeutet durch hilfe der sprache line
bringt die vernunft ihre wichtigsten
leistungs standen nämlich dass
übereinstimmung der handel mehrerer
individuum das planvolle zusammenwirkung
viele tausende die zivilisation den
staat ferner die wissenschaft das
aufbewahren
frühere erfahrungen der zusammenfassen
dass das gemeinsamen in ein begriff das
mitteilen der wahrheit das verbreiten
des irrtums das denken und dichten liegt
ordnen und die superstition also der
aber klar das tier lernt den tod erst im
tote kennen der mensch geht mit
bewusstsein in jeder stunde seinem tod
näher und es macht selbst dem das leben
bisweilen bedenklich denn nicht schon am
ganzen lebens selbst diesen charakter
der stetigen fange ich doch erkannt hat
wie schopenhauer hat also immer schon
erkannt aber selbst optimistisch
denkender menschen selbst die betrifft
aber zu dieser gedanke hauptsächlich
innerhalb der mensch philosophien und
religionen
ob jedoch dasjenige was wir ihm mit
recht an seinem handeln über alles ruhig
schätzen dass freiwillige recht tun und
der eben mut der gesinnung ja die
vorfrucht einer jeder jener beiden
gewesen ist ungewiss als sichere ihnen
allein angehörige erzeugnisse beide und
produktion der vernunft auf diesem wege
stehen hingegen da die wunderlichsten
abenteuerlichsten meinungen der
philosophen verschiedenen schulen und
die seltsamsten bisweilen auch grausamen
gebräuche der priester verschiedene
religionen
ja
okay sagt er hier und das betrifft jetzt
unser thema des seminars besonders er
sagt jetzt zeile sieben sprachen seine
sechs noch genauer sprache ist das erste
zeugnis und das notwendige werkzeug
seiner vernunft
daher wird im griechischen usw sofort
sprache vernunft dämlich bezeichnet
[Musik]
ja ist es wirklich so dass die sprache
mit hilfe der verlust ihrer wichtigsten
leistung zustande bringt das
übereinstimmen der handel mehrere
individuum das planvolle zusammenwirkung
vieler tausender die zivilisationen
start
was ist der grund dafür dass jetzt
schopenhauer sagt die sprache gehört
nicht den verstand sondern der vernunft
an
überlegen sie noch mal auf was diese
sachen die wir hier jetzt hin
geschrieben haben das ist jetzt das
entscheidende was die sprache
auszeichnet
als vernünftiges instrument
ein kleines wörtchen habe ich hin
geschrieben unter die vernunft
abstrakten
also die sprache ist offen sich etwas
was von diesen konkreten kausalität
bezügen abstrahiert begriffe bildet
begriffe sind letztendlich abstraktion
könnte auch sagen oder letztendlich sind
begriffe etwas was über dem sich
zeitlich vollziehenden befinden wobei
wenn ich beim habe sie bitte frau habe
ich eine vorstellung vom baum ich habe
bestimmte die rhetorische merkmal des
baumes aber ich habe nichts kann schauen
wie ich es mehr
ich sehe den bauern nicht ich sehe den
gedanken vielleicht vielleicht sehe ich
ihn nicht meine gedanken wenn ich das
wort beim lesen
vielleicht denke ich wir nicht beim
lesen oder den begriff des baumes bilde
nur an bestimmte eigenschaften bauen es
muss jetzt nicht sinnlich konkret sein
das ist also die abstraktion der sprache
durch wörter abstrahieren wir von den
konkreten empirische zugänglichen
verhältnissen bis zu einem solchen stand
dass wir jetzt bauen haben als das wort
und dass sich auf eine realität bezieht
baum das laut bild baum oder auch die
buchstabenfolge baum hat rein gar nichts
mit dem konkreten baum zu tun mit
irgendein baum gar nichts überhaupt
nichts ist eine puk abstraktion in
anderen sprachen heißt dieses wort
anders tree oder was auch immer
anders ist es jetzt zum beispiel mit
unserem buch intelligent notierte creme
oder dem raben im rahmen ist es anders
das wort habe im deutschen team seit
otto ohne motto poetisches bord was in
einer beziehung steht zum konkreten
haben nämlich insofern das wort den laut
desg rechtens des raam haben's nachahmt
also rabl ist eine matte poetisches wort
da wird dieser laut des rahmens im board
selbst mit aufgenommen aber auch da
würde man sagen ja gut er habe gut es
gibt verschiedene tiere die solche laute
wir aber jetzt produzieren das muss
jetzt auch nicht mehr direkte bedeutung
bzw
graf ich nur sagen
das sind in mexikanischen richtig dieses
zeige dieses zeigen genau das ist gut
ist das ist richtig genau da kann ich
nicht mehr zeigen genau gute beobachtung
dieses gegen texanische dieses zeigen
dass das dass es geht wirklich nur ein
ganz kurzen augenblicken eigentlich in
stund an wenn ich sage wenn mich jemand
fragt was sage ich dass wenn ich jetzt
auf eine vergangenes ereignis deuten
soll das geht nicht
die vergangenheit entzieht sich der
index qualität jetzt endlich wobei ich
meine sind jahren objekte nur ist nur
objekte wie zb sachverhalte die tatsache
dass das so und so war das kann ich
sowieso nie bedeuten ich kann ihnen nur
auf objekte deutlich kann sich auf
sachverhalte deuten also wenn es
komplexer wird dann und es ist ja häufig
so dass ich ein sachverhalt darstellen
möchte die mehrere objekte involviert
dann muss ich auf das zeigen auf des
heftes und dann ist nicht klar in
welcher verbindung stehen ich würde ja
da nur logisch an und zeichen dazwischen
machen dass das das aber es kann ja sein
ich will sagen das erste war die ursache
von 2
das kann ich mit glos und zeigen nicht
mehr so hinbekommen weil ursache wieder
schon zeitlichkeit anzahl die gute
bemerkung also durchaus in mexikanische
könnte man sagen
durch das aufgehen gegenwärtigen braucht
es hier keine sprache weil es die
dimension der zeit unabhängig von
dagegen warten ich hatte da reicht der
objekt bezug
sachverhalte spielen auch keine rolle
und daraus folgt offensichtlich dass sie
keine sprache bild also sprache
zusammengefasst nach schopenhauer ist
der gewonnene gas sprache ist die
abstraktion der vernunft inbegriffen
und das ist natürlich jetzt ein riesen
punkt der uns im seminar betrifft haben
tiere ansprache ja das war eine frage
hantieren sprache schopenhauer würde
sagen nein
dennoch sind es brüder dass menschen sie
haben vernunft und verstand sie können
irgendwie reagieren auch so kausal
verhältnisse ab eben nicht begrifflich
und genau betrachtet würde schopenhauer
aussagen ist es so schlimm für die tiere
nicht weil sie dadurch viele leiden
nicht haben sie gehen in den freuden
oder leiden der gegenwart leben auf die
können aber nie so hoch aus schlagen wie
es eben leiden und folgen tun können vor
allem natürlich leiden würde
schopenhauer aussagen die antizipation
des todes ist für schopenhauer wohl sehr
schlimm und für ihn einige lebensform
und so war es denn wir haben jetzt ihre
einfach nicht weil sie keine sprachen
kann vernunft haben und natürlich hier
sagte auch noch am ende
[Musik]
auch der wille letztendlich sagt
schuppen habe ich glaube es hat hier die
sind zitate vor genau überlegte
entscheidung des willens
die gibt es dann auch nicht wenn wir
nicht die vernunft haben und die
begriffe haben
also sagten mehrere motive also die wahl
zwischen wirklichen motiven zwischen die
wirkliche wahl zwischen mehreren motiven
wie setzt voraus dass die motive
abstraktes vorgestellt werden wenn wir
jetzt nur die konkreten motive an uns
spüren hier in zwang hier hunger durst
und so weiter und so fort dann können
wir darüber nicht irgendwie reflektieren
wir müssen sie abstrakt fassen wir
müssen sagen ich habe jetzt hier diesen
wunsch mussten auf den begriff bringen
ich habe diesen wunsch und ich habe
diesen wunsch dieses motiv ich muss sie
beide gleichermaßen vor augen haben
das heißt ich kann sie nicht mehr als
solche durchleben muss sie abstrahieren
dann kann ich sie auf derselben ebene
des bewusstseins bringen vergleichen
auf diese abstrakten vergleiches ebene
kann ich danach sagt schopenhauer
entscheidung treffen ich kann überlegen
reflektieren
man könnte sagen so mit harry frankfurt
dessen second order wurde schon ein
bisschen könnte und sagen ich gehe nicht
mehr in den unmittelbaren koalitionen
auf die konkreten ich triebe uns weil
die mit beeinträchtigen sondern ich
abstrahieren davon gehe auf eine zweite
ebene und vergleiche die dann
begrifflich miteinander oder angesichts
anderer maßstäbe miteinander könnte man
sagen dass das eine form vielleicht von
wir uns verhältnissen
wir wollen in milden seite beeinflussen
können
welche optionen riesen debatte bei
schopenhauer ob der willensfreiheit
kennt oder handlungsfreiheit man könnte
jetzt zeit die man das dem willen
vorhält er denkt ja auch den willen der
in letzer hält sich nicht individuell
sind die welt als es wieder die ganze
welt ist ein fehler aber wenn wir die
motive die auch will endlich strukturen
dem willen vorhalten dann haben wir
schon mal abstrahiert von ihnen wir
müssen das dann eben diesem universal
wird nachricht nicht als individuen das
wäre das entscheidende willensfreiheit
scheint individualität voraussetzen
genau was unsere letztendlichen
eigentlichen maximen sind dies stehe
nicht zur verfügung
jedenfalls scheint daher seine besondere
oft eine gewisse form von freiheit auch
mit der vernunft in verbindung zu setzen
das gesetz ist also das nächste thema
freiheit tiere während diesem sinne
nicht sofort dass alle dieses und
mannigfaltigen und so weit reichen
äußerungen aus einem gemeinschaftlichen
prinzip entspringen aus jeder besonderen
geisteskraft die der mensch vor dem
tiere voraus hat und welche man vernunft
genannt hat ist die einstimmige meinung
aller zeiten und völker auch wissen alle
menschen sehr wohl die äußerungen dieses
vermögens zu erkennen und zu sagen was
vernünftig was unnötig sei wo die
vernunft im gegensatz mit anderen
fähigkeiten und eigenschaften des
menschen auftritt und endlich was wegen
des mangels derselben auch vom klügsten
tieren nie zu erwarten steht die
philosophen aller zeiten sprechen dem
ganzen auch übereinstimmung mit jeder
allgemeinen kenntnis der vernunft und
habe überdies einige besonders wichtige
äußerung derselben hervor wie die
beherrschung der effekte und
leidenschaften die fähigkeit schlüsse zu
machen und allgemeine prinzipien sogar
solche die vor allem erfahrungen
gewissen aufzustellen und so weiter
solche prinzipien die fahrerfahrung
gewiss sind aufzustellen das sind
natürlich da denkt er vielleicht erkannt
da sind solche ab rio rischen prinzipien
transzendentale beginnt die kausalität
als eine ist es jetzt endlich kausale
schlüssel zu folgen
also irgendwie so einen intuitiven
begriff davon zu haben was ist jetzt die
ursache was die wirkung dass anderes ist
zu sagen das ist kausalität
das ist dann sind abstrakt das prinzip
dass würden tiere nicht sagen dass das
kausalität ist ein ding aber sie würden
eben innerhalb dieses zusammenhangs
verursache wirkung springen ok
als schopenhauer scheint doch hier ob
trotz seiner sympathie als brüder zu
unrecht klassischen klassische
unterscheiden zwischen mensch und tier
zu vertreten
die frage ist jetzt natürlich der ist
nicht ganz so extrem wie descartes der
sagt das sind lose marschieren
es ist klar aber er geht auch nicht so
weit wie pierre bei der letztendlich
sagt die menschliche die die menschliche
seele und die tierische seele
die sind nur durch äußere umstände
begrenzt sind von der potenz nach sind
die zu allem mindern würde würde doch
widersprechen gerade man könnte jetzt
hier meine hausarbeit genauer
untersuchen
ja wie wieder verstand jetzt nach
schopenhauer bei tieren funktioniert wie
ich leistungen ihnen nach schopenhauer
vorenthalten werden müssen durch die
vernunft
das scheint jetzt sanierungszeit
verständnis zu hängen ganz entscheidend
schopenhauer sagt ihre haben nur
gegenwärtiges denken
frage es stimmt das kann man sich nicht
auch bedenken dass das schon eine
gewisse antizipation enthalten ist diese
antizipation überhaupt zeitliche
struktur oder das antizipation eine
logische struktur
man muss ja unterscheiden sie sagen wenn
ich das mache dann passiert das
das würde wohl sagen als sagen antrag
strichen würde sie wohl denken wenn ich
das mache dann stars frage ist dieses
dann ist es eine zeitliche dimension
dieses dank das ist damit notwendige
meiste zeit her geht hier
zeit aber gezeigt oder ist es nicht die
eine logische beziehung bin laden will
logische beziehung sind ja nicht zeitig
zu denken den adern beetes hat nichts
mit mit zeit zu tun
es könnte sogar gar keine zeit
dazwischen will sein realer betrachtung
ist irrelevant ist die ganz andere
kategorie
da
runde hätte
würden sie dann also nichts sagen dass
krähen über zeitbegriff verfügt
ja
seit dem 1
ja das ist er
genau also wir müssen logische folgerung
beziehung durchaus von zeitlichen
verhältnissen unterscheiden nein wir
kennen zum beispiel fall das
eichhörnchen ihre nüsse vergraben
eintragen und dann kann man sich fangen
ja aber denkt das hören wir jetzt an die
zukunft seine altersvorsorge oder zu was
aber könnte dann könnte man natürlich
sagen gut das ist beim eichhörnchen ein
tourer instinkt dieser zeit wird dieses
programm geschaltet jetzt vergraben sie
es halt anfangen als überlebensstrategie
oder punkt genau so im gedächtnis
scheint auch notwendig zu sein um zeit
bewusstsein zu haben also erinnerungen
erinnerungsvermögen
ich denke ein wesen das
erinnerungsvermögen hat hat durchaus
zeitliche begriffe in rudimentärer form
also bei der gräben ich mir einfach
nicht sicher
das könnte man sich überlegen april zeit
bewusst sagen noch ganz im bilde
wichtig und dann muss man auch noch
unterscheiden zwischen
erinnerungsvermögen und zeit bewusst
sein
ich meine es ist ja das eine sich zu
erinnern aber hat man davon dann schon
ein begriff der zeit oder ein zeitliches
denke ja
immer mehr dazu zu sagen das ist
instinkt alle gleich machen
was anderes machen als er
hierzu müsste
also das können wir zwar offen lassen
wir müssen jetzt weiter schauen
also wir haben praktisch die drei fragen
haben tiere verfügen tiere über sprache
das hatten wir ganz am anfang auch
gesagt geistigkeit geist sollte man
immer konkret an akten oder phänomen
festmachen geist also hier sprache
vielleicht bewusst sein
denken
hier sagt eben schopenhauer nein tiere
haben keine sprache also hätten sie
vielleicht auch kein geist sie haben
aber verstand fuß sein selbstbewusstsein
und denken das ist jetzt die spannende
frage könnte sie jetzt vor
können tiere nach schopenhauer denken
wir denken begriffliches denken ist dann
nicht wir haben keine abstraktionen wir
haben kein begriff aber wenn das denken
ist der vision zb instrumentelle
vernunft sage jetzt mal oder verstand
mit mittel zweck wenn dass das
entscheidend ist dann haben sie denn der
würde sagen tiere könnte falls sie
diesen kausalität relation nachgehen
können sie denken in kausalität platze
jetzt über die frage wo verorten wir das
denken im verstand und vernunft im volk
erfolgen oder herausfinden von qualitäts
verhältnissen
das ist fertigung genug dann kann es dir
denken nach der wm verschoben haben
offensichtlich denke ich ihr nicht mal
denken verschoben habe sicherlich
begrifflich wäre und auch zukunfts
dimensionen mit berücksichtigen
das ding
bei mussten
gut verstand
die standortfrage okay das würde
schopenhauer sicherlich sagen begriffe
sind dann
die tiere nicht denken können ich denke
dass das eine konsequenz aus
schopenhauers theorie bürger
wie gesagt der wie tun würde sagen tiere
können denken weil sie kausal
verhältnisse herausfinden können
so und jetzt lesen wir mal einen endlich
einen neuen text von norden kommen
gedankenlose tieren und er geht jetzt
hier in seinem text der uns und
deutscher übersetzung vorliegt auf die
card etwas einer sagt wenn man die karte
liest und zum erstmal dessen ansicht auf
dessen ansicht stößt tiere seien
automaten ohne bewusstsein ist nun
erstaunt ist man erstaunt wie zb diese
autohändler in seinem kürzlich
erschienen buch regie tanz schreibtisch
zitat die berühmt berüchtigte doktrin
das tier automatismus vielleicht der
contra intuitivsten punkt indikator
sophie die tat selbst hat sich nicht für
den konto intuitiven charakter seiner
these interessieren er stellt fest die
überzeugung dass tiere nach einem
inneren prinzip handeln wie jenes in uns
selbst das heißt mit hilfe einer seele
die empfindungen und leidenschaften wie
unsere eigenen hat sei ein
hervorragendes beispiel für ein
vorurteil
man könne die gründe gegen diese
überzeugung nicht vorbringen sagte ohne
sich dem sport von kindern und geistes
schwachen auszusetzen
also bekam ist der ausgangspunkt und
diese ausgangspunkt ist berühmt
berüchtigt
ich hoffe meine erinnerung also die
automatismus sagt macht die karte den
wir ausführlich gelesen haben tiere sind
so beschaffen dass wir um ihre handlung
sage ich jetzt mal die ihre tätigkeiten
zu verstehen oder zu erklären wie er
nicht davon ausgehen müssen dass sie
lebendig sind
wir können die tierischen aktionen
verstehen angemessen beschreiben wenn
wir darauf verzichten
in ein lebensprinzip zu unterstellen
wenn wir davon ausgehen sie seien nur
automaten das ist jetzt natürlich ein
unterschied das so zu formulieren oder
zusagen tiere sind automaten unterschied
ist ganz wichtig die karte nicht hier
sind automatisch ab wenn wir tiere
verstehen wollen angemessen genügt es
sie als automat nachzufassen wir können
sie natürlich auch noch als etwas
lebendiges auffassen
aber dann machen wir in weitere annahmen
die wir im sinne der unter logische
sparsamkeit des prinzips nicht
eigentlich brauchen kann
und das ist doch eine ganz andere these
also sagen tiere sind automat es sollten
immer im gedächtnis behalten
es ist es bei decarta sonne
methodologische sachen apps
theologisches sachen aus
erkenntnistheoretische sicht genug ist
um prima fazit die ganzen tätigkeit zu
verstehen
zusagen tiere sind automaten
alles andere können wir auch noch gerne
annehmen aber es würde viel zu viele
voraussetzungen bedeuten sehr nicht
notwendig und es anzunehmen
das sagt deka hier den 150 jahre nach
descartes tod war die doktrin des tier
automatismus gegenstand vielen
kontroversen einige gegner dieser
doktrin behaupteten sogar die kt diana
seien zu tieren absichtlich brutal über
die philosophen und logiker von pro jahr
sagt fontaine
sie versetzen und den hunden mit
vollkommener gleichgültigkeit schläge
und machen sich lustig über jene die die
geschöpfe bemitleiden als hätten sie
schmerzen empfunden
die sachen tiere seien uhren die schreie
die sie ausschließen wenn sie geschlagen
würden sei lediglich das geräusch einer
kleinen feder die berührt worden sei
der ganze körper aber so gefühllos sehr
interessant weil jetzt hier noch ein
weiterer aspekt reinkommt sich qualia
der von ihm kann man sagen dass qualia
sind
die zustände wie es ist wie es sich
anfühlt wie es ist eine fledermaus zu
sein wie es sich anfühlt zahnschmerzen
zu haben
the sun und nach dieser schilderung
würden also die anhänger von descartes
tieren qualia absprechen
tiere haben keine metallen ist kein
phänomen das bewusstsein tiere erzeugen
irgendwelche laute irgendwelche töne
oder sonstige geräusche auf basis eines
mechanismus der selbst kein bewusstseins
phänomen darstellt genauso kann man sich
fragen ja wie fühlt es sich an einen
computer zu sein da würde man sagen er
ein computer fühlt sich nicht an
computer hat kein gefühl das ist gibt es
eine falsche frage
computer funktioniert hat
er hat kein bewusstsein er ist nicht
mehr werden und er kann zwar dinge
registrieren
ich kann da irgendwas eintippen ich kann
mir so machen dass die seite wechseln
das hat zurückgehen da wird halten
befehle ausgeführt dass es in punkt
output der rat etwas durch aber dieses
durch rattern ist ohne bewusstsein und
ist auch vieles vernünftige anzunehmen
der computer hat kein bewusstsein um die
sache zu erklären auch ich nicht von
bewusstsein ausgehen ich gebe was
eigentlich bekommt was raus dass
genügend e card wird jetzt
offensichtlich so tiere verstehen input
output maschine gibt es ein bekommen was
raus
ja ein geräusch einer kleinen feder die
berührt worden
der ganze körper aber sei gefühllos die
karte selbst vermerkt zu diesem punkt
dass meine absicht nicht zu sehr
gegenüber tieren grausam zu nachsichtig
gegenüber den menschen ist weil sie vom
verstanden weil sie vom verdacht eines
verbrechens los spricht wenn sie tiere
essen oder töten das sind
also wir dürfen nach descartes tiere
essen und töten weil sie herrin wo
automaten sind
ich frage mich gerade war es zu dieser
zeit überhaupt ein problem wäre es ein
problem gewesen tiere zur tötung zu
essen es jetzt immer davon ausgegangen
wird dass sie lebendige wesen sind denke
auch nicht mehr heute tage ja auch nicht
halt nur die frage wie man sie tötet
das ist immer die frage sowieso generell
jetzt gesehen natürlich gibt es gute
gründe und es gibt hier ethik usw
wenn schon töten dann bietet auf eine
menschliche art sag jetzt mal so ne aber
dass man tiere töten kann ist nicht
verboten wobei und jetzt kommen
interessante sache die vielleicht auch
für unser thema wichtig ist ich war vor
kurzem den usa vier monate und bei einer
wg und meine mitbewohner mit ihr habe
ich unterhalten amerikaner und er fragte
mich stimmt es dass es in deutschland
erlaubt ist pferde zu essen sag ich war
schon als ich habe es zwar lesen
vielleicht mein pferd ist aber so was
kriegt man durchaus in delikatessen
werden sagte das ist in den usa verboten
pferde darf man nicht essen ja davon
nicht dann sage ich ja das ist ungefähr
so wie wenn man in deutschland hunde
essen würden
wir haben es jetzt nur andersrum also
hunde essen wir sind deutschland absolut
verpönt
werden
es ist das darf darf man vielleicht auch
nicht ist doch interessant den usa darf
man keine pferde essen in deutschland
schon
ich sage jetzt nicht dass man usa hunde
essen war wahrscheinlich auch nicht aber
deutschland darf man es eben nicht was
folgt aus dieser tatsache
ich habe mir noch sohn reim daraus
gemacht dass sind usa das war also meine
theorie einfach das pferd so der beste
gefährte des menschen als da eben noch
der westen nicht besiegelt war brauchte
man es für unbedingt das pferd wie beim
cowboy das pferd ist so ein guter freund
der eine neben hilft in deutschland wir
sind viel zu eng bewohnt der sturm werde
sagt jetzt mal nur verstrichen
während der hund vielleicht in
deutschland so der gute beschützer ist
oder so in engeren verhältnis mit dem
man eng aufeinander lebt ist ein hund
bestimmt sinnvoller als ein pferd zu
halten denke ich in mitteleuropa
jedenfalls gesehen also folgt daraus
irgendwie so dass man ein problem hat es
essen also ich glaube der autor hier
macht auf wichtigen punkt aufmerksam
man kann dieses mensch tier verhältnis
oder auch nur die frage der geist des
tieres sehr gut daran gemessen ob man
tiere essen darf oder nicht
also mal ganz ganz pragmatisch tiere
essen fragezeichen
man würde jetzt nicht sagen man darf
indes deswegen in deutschland kein hund
essen weil der hund so intelligent
eingestuft wird oder in usa nicht weil
das pferd intelligent eingestuft
genau die sind ja ähnlich intelligent
es hat als offensichtlich was mit dieser
nähe zum menschen
das pferd ist ein us-amerikaner rat dass
menschen klingt ja so ein cowboy es ist
unverzichtbares mittel und deutschland
ist der hund offensichtlich täter ist
war als mein schluss aber vielleicht
sehen sie anders
da kommen wir
trotzdem
ich habe
ja
richtig es ist richtig und die usa auf
kunden ihrer fläche auf grund der
grösseren ausdehnung dort ist es
vielleicht leichter dem pferd zu
personalisieren als es in deutschland
möglich dass mitteleuropa
und ja ich kenne ich war ja das ist
richtig das kann durchaus kulturelle
gründe haben er hat auf jeden fall
kultur religion aber ist doch
interessant wie das abweicht von kultur
zu kultur
der war ganz schockiert hat ihm gesagt
hat ich habe bestimmt marktes alarmieren
konnte er nicht verstehen
ich würde jetzt nicht mehr tun aber es
ist unvorstellbar den usa werde zuerst
es geht in den kopf nicht rein das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn man hier sagen
würde ich habe den hund gegessen ich
weiß nicht vielleicht in china
es ist unmöglich würden wieder an die
nationale sieht man so ein bisschen mir
geht es da nicht nicht darum die
differenzen zu betonen sind einfach die
tatsache wie man das verhältnis zwischen
mensch und tier wird das essen das ist
interessanter faktor über dieses essens
verhältnis ist etwas ganz anderes als
ein tier als haustier zu haben wenn es
um die frage das es geht ist die
gretchenfrage wie hältst du es mit dem
pferd mit dem bund
gewesen die anderen haben sie nun für
die missionale haben das aus getreide
und jetzt ist das bild
wirklich wichtig dafür einen seite
ich glaube ich
es ist es billiger wir könnten jetzt mal
eine exkursion machen im rahmen dieses
seminars und mal schauen was auf dem
viktualienmarkt allesamt ihr fleisch und
mit welchen argumenten und ob es dann
tatsächlich teurer ist wenn ich das eine
gute gute frage weil sich glaube ich
auch die wertschätzung dieser normative
status des tiers auch irgendwie preis
vielleicht wieder strömt jetzt endlich
dann auch wieder wie viele man hält und
so weiter aber das sind spannende
faktoren das ist eher
kulturgeschichtlich
kulturwissenschaftlich aber es spielt in
unserer thema mit benutzten benutzen
das ist interessant also die volle
ausbeutung des tieres völlig
industrielle verwertung nico muss man ja
dann in den besten jahren eigentlich
schlachten oder bei einem kalbfleisch in
den allerersten jahren zu gehen wo die
ganze produktion und stattgefunden hat
sie sehen ist natürlich auch ein höchst
problematische verständnis von tier das
man das team natürlich so der ausnutzt
wie es nur geht also die totale
verwertung das ist natürlich durchaus
problematisch das soll uns jetzt aber
nicht interessieren diese normative
punkte sind einfach die tatsache wie man
mit tieren umgeht aus welchen
gesichtspunkten
die ganz kurze stellen
deshalb kann man sagt also es gibt
keinen direkten wert der tiere sondern
gewährte tiere wird ihr am menschen
gemessen und des tiers exemplar also
dass die würde des tieres bemisst sich
nur an der würde des menschen im umgang
mit dem tier
weil der mensch leben durch einen groben
umgang mit tieren selbst moralischen
schaden nimmt deswegen sollten wir
tierischen ist aber nur so ein
instrument ell werte gedanke das tier so
interessant was die kattas bemerkenswert
dass die karte in einem brief an problem
ich weiß nicht genau wie henry henry
moore wahrscheinlich schreibt es könne
nicht bewiesen werden dass es keine
gedanken in tieren gebe weil der
menschliche geist nicht dass in ihre
herzen hinein reicht angesichts seiner
auffassung dass gedanken nicht
körperlich und nicht heimisch sind hier
ist dieser erstaunliche bemerkung warum
formulierte es so als ginge es darum was
in den tieren ist ist dies eine metapher
bezugnahme auf die herzen corder ist
bestimmt metaphorisch aber die idee dass
unser geist nicht in tiere hineinschauen
kann um zu ermitteln ob sich dort
irgendwelche gedanken befinden oder
nicht scheint nicht nur eine metapher zu
sein da sie als erklärung war schwer
weil dafür angeboten wird warum wir
nicht beweisen können dass tiere nicht
denken
in dem selben brief legte card den
hauptgrund für seine ansicht dass tiere
keine gedanken haben da nehme ich dass
sie keine wirkliche sprache gebrauchen
eine solche sprache sagt er ist das
einzig sichere anzeichen verein in
seinem körper verborgenen gedanken einem
weiteren brief an
drückt er sich genau so aus er sagt nur
die sprache zeige einen körper
verborgenen gedanken in corpore latenten
ich habe zuvor ein abschnitt zitiert in
dem er von der seele als einem inneren
prinzip spricht man ein top ist
folgender obwohl die karts formal die
position vertritt dass seele oder geist
und gedanken ganz und gar nicht räumlich
sind und damit weder innerhalb noch
außerhalb von irgendetwas sein können
steht ja eigentlich dennoch sehr unter
dem einfluss des gängigen metaphysischen
builders das gedanken innerhalb einer
person auftreten
diese gedanken etwas innere singen und
das finde jetzt spannend was jetzt hier
noch einmal betont wird die karte ist
nicht so dumm dass er jetzt sagt tiere
haben keine gedanken
das sagt nur wir können es nicht
beweisen beweis fehlt
weil der menschliche geist nicht hinein
reicht
und der grund das anzeichen das hatten
wir auch schon gesehen ist das dass sie
keine wirkliche sprache gebrauchen
was war nochmal das argument bei
descartes und dem text wir gelesen haben
recht zu beginn des seminars wissen sie
den grund noch was was die karte dafür
anführt dass tiere keine sprache haben
worin zeigt sich dass dass tiere keine
sprache haben oder anders gefragt
welchen erfordernissen muss nicht
sprachlich genügen um als sprache gelten
zu können
denken sie noch mal an die vernunft als
universales zumindest die karte
also dass
immer noch
ist das so
genau hier haben vielleicht keine
begriffe und was noch wichtiger ist sie
haben gesagt genau die grammatik oder
auch noch die syntax also dass tiere
jetzt nicht in der lage sind ihre
deutung tragenden elemente in
verschiedenen kontexten anzuordnen und
neue bedeutung zu generieren
dieses komposition ali teetz prinzip
dass wir das auch die anordnung der
lauterer zeichen darüber entscheidet was
für eine bedeutung es gibt und das
scheint bei tieren so nicht so sein
diesem maße also die karts sagt die
vernunft ist ein universal organ
ich hatte jetzt so interpretiert ist ein
organ zweiter stufe es ist kein
organisches wie unser herz und lunge und
so weiter oder unsere hände und so
weiter sondern die vernunft ist so eine
zentrale schaltstelle die den organen
der bestimmte funktionen gibt sagte sie
noch genug
genau syntax semantik diese ganzen
sachen die machen eine sprache ist sehr
komplex sehr flexibel und diese
flexibilität sagt jedenfalls die karts
die hat die tierische sprache wenn es
überhaupt eine sprache tierische
kommunikationsform nicht
wenn man die karte liest und zum ersten
mal auf dessen ansicht stößt tiere seien
automaten
das haben wir schon gehabt mit seiner
behauptung tiere wird nicht denken meint
die karts bestimmt dass sie nicht
reflektieren oder meditieren aber meinte
er auch dass sie weder gefühl noch
empfindungen noch irgendeine art von
bewusstsein haben wir wissen aus der
zweiten meditation das fühlen sind tiere
denken gitarrist tiere also nicht denken
dann fühlen sie nicht in die
leidenschaften der seele legt dar dass
der seele hause gedanken nichts
zugeschrieben werden sollte und dass es
zwei arten von gedanken gibt nämlich
aktive und passive neuen stiftung der
leidenschaften gedanken sind und tiere
keine gedanken haben haben sie auch
keine leidenschaften wie etwa furcht
oder zorn
passanten in der zweiten meditation das
wird häufig übersehen dieser meditation
von descartes sagte fühlen ist eine form
von denken denkt man häufig nicht und
denkt dieses geräts dieses cookie tanz
diese denken die substanz prädikat
würden moment nur kognitive akte
betreffend künftig schließen also ganz
rationale aktie bezeichnet politik gibt
also eine ganze liste an akten tiefer in
geistiger natur sind die teleskope tanz
aus man sagt wollen nicht wollen ist
kommentare jahren von 1 ist korrekt und
sind tiere auch als auch wo nationale
willentlichen aktivitäten von denen
viele sagen würden die haben nichts mit
denken zu tun
inhalt der betriebe oder so gezählt card
auch mit zur wm
ihre alte nicht denken dann fühlen sie
nicht aha
interessant also jetzt er kommt jetzt
auch diese diesen punkt dass sie keine
quali haben und nichts fühlen weil sie
nicht denken
bei denken letztendlich für die card so
ein bisschen was auch qualia charakter
für die frage ist fühlen spanier sind es
quasi fühlen könnte man schon sagen
etwas für gefühle etwas spüre dass ich
habe das phänomenale bewusstsein
das sagt die karts dieses phänomenale
bewusstsein ich glaube dass es
entscheidend das ist bewusstsein ist
das macht es zu einer respekt was
intelligenz
das ist ein weiterer grund warum er ihn
das abspricht diese diese qualia weil
sie nicht denken und die quali als
gefühle ein fall von comparis und
zitieren
andererseits sagte karte einem seiner
briefe an nur verspreche den tieren
empfindungen nicht ab insofern sie von
einem körper organ abhängen wie einen
brief an den marquis von new was auch
immer schreibt er dass hunde pferde und
affen manchmal leidenschaften wie furcht
hoffnung und freude ausdruck geben
jedoch sagt der mann weiteren brief
tiere hätten keine wirklichen gefühle
oder wirkliche leidenschaft für
ressentiments repression damit wir diese
offensichtlichen widersprüche aus dem
weg schaffen können müssen wir genau
verstehen was die karte mit gedanken
meint einen wichtigen und schwierigen
abschnitte dritten meditation sagt sie
einige meiner gedanken sind gleichsam
bilder von dingen die name idee trifft
genau genommen nur auf sie zu wenn ich
etwa an einen menschen oder an
eigentlich mehrere wurde an den himmel
wo dann ein engel oder ein gott denke
habe andere gedanken haben außerdem
andere formen zb wenn ich will wenn ich
fürchte wenn ich bin ich verneine dann
erfasse ich immer ein ding als den
gegenstand eines gedankens
in denen meine gedanken in den gedanken
schließlich aber etwas weiteres als eine
ähnlichkeit des dinges 1
und einige dieser gedanken werden
wohnungen oder effekte genannt andere
usa
ok also das ist das entscheidende hier
das sagte auch ein ger zweiten
meditation wollen fürchten bejahen von
einem das sind gedanken besitzt die rics
kochen tanzen
volumeneffekte das alles gehört zur
disco kitas
es ist alles interessant descartes hat
einen sera zionistisches verständnis von
qualys dem volk das er dass den tieren
nur ungern zuspricht
wir haben keine wirklichen gefühle den
fehlt dieses cookie tanz dieser
kognitive ich glaube die charaktere dass
jeder denkt vorgang zunächst eine idee
enthält mit idee meinte eine
repräsentation deshalb nennt er sie bild
sie ist die erste form eines gedankens
denn in diesem abschnitt den ausdruck in
die verwendet wäre eine idee das was
gewöhnlich mit proposition gemeint ist
oder mit proportionalen gehalte ideen
gemäss descartes bejaht oder verneint
werden können
die idee von gott etwa könnte man mit
dem satz es gibt ein höchstes
vollkommenes wiesen oder mit der
normalisierten phase die existenz eines
höchsten vorkommen wesens ausdrücken
in beiden fällen könnte das was
ausgedrückt wurde bejaht oder verneint
also die karte damit etwas eine ruhige
tanz ist muss sie eine oder damit etwas
zur disco tanz zählt muss sie eine idee
sein
eine idee muss trial oder verneint
werden können das heißt sie muss einen
proportionalen gehalt haben proposition
sind gedanken könnte man sagen diese
dass form gebracht wird können also ich
glaube ich denke ich fühle das kann man
ja alles fertig hat auch so einfügen ich
fühle
komme dass das sich zahnschmerzen haben
und so weiter und so fort
das ist die proposition aale struktur
natürlich geht mir zu einer proposition
8 uhr irgendwie auch einher als dadurch
dass eine position so viel mit diese das
formen hat dass sie bewusst ist es
scheint mir das zentrale ziel seien
würden sie sagen dass es pro position
aale gehalte gibt ihm denken die nicht
bewusst sind schwierig
ich glaube schon das bewusstsein hier
eine große rolle spielt und descartes
würde offensichtlich das bewusstsein
die tiere absprechen in ihren gedanken
oder was auch immer in ihren gefühlen
die zweite form von gedanken delikat in
diesem abschnitt erwähnt blickt nicht
die proposition ahlen gehalt sondern
eine art einstellung gegenüber allen
proposition ahlen gehalt eingenommen
wird zb eine einstellung des bildes
vereins wollens fürchten soder hoffen
jemand könnte bejahen oder verneinen
wollen hoffen oder fürchten dass ein
höheres vollkommen das wesen existiert
der kern jeder mentalen tätigkeit ist
eine proposition das heißt eine idee das
heißt an gedanken erstens in ein gedanke
im zweiten sinne ist das was man heute
etwa proposition alle einstellungen oder
mentale verfassung meint
damit ist jetzt gemeint ich will dass
ich verhalte mich so eine position ich
fürchte dass das und das der fall ist
ich hoffe dass das in das der fall ist
und auch das ist natürlich etwas was
ziemlich rational schon ist wo dann die
karts sagen kann so was hatten hier
einfach nicht hat er fast jetzt diese
ganzen akte sehr sehr nationalistisch
auf selbst fühlen uns jetzt sofort steht
der abschied aus der dritten meditation
zeigt deutlich wie die tat sich
vorstellt was man die mentale seite
einer emotion wie zum beispiel furcht
nennen könnte wenn ich mich fürchte so
sagte dann erfasse ich etwas das heißt
ich begreife in einem bestimmten
positionen einen bestimmten proposition
ahlen gehalt etwa dass sich einer gefahr
gegenüber stehen dann werde ich die
mentale verfassung oder einstellung der
fullhd auf diesen proposition ahlen
gehalt an treffe ich im dschungel auf
eine lösung zur hätte ich die karts
zufolge zwei formen von gedanken die
erste wäre eine repräsentation
das heißt ein proposition aale gehalt
wie etwa dem satz die loewe wird
möglicherweise angreifen ausgedrückt
werden können die der zweite gedanken
die zweite danken form könnte die
mentale verfassung der furcht sein
die verbindung dieser beiden gedanken
formen die sich dann etwa dem satz ich
fürchte löwe wird mich möglicherweise
angreifen
sie können
richtig also hier stellt sich wirklich
die frage geht das wirklich in uns vor
wenn wir an löwen im dschungel begegnen
ich glaube er gibt es zweifel weil da
wird doch ihr sohn überlebensmodus
aktiviert also ich glaube also sind wir
mal ein bisschen naturwissenschaft
evolutionär gesprochen wenn in so einer
situation erst proposition aldi halte
kognitiv erarbeitet werden müssten
dann wäre das ein evolutionärer nachteil
weil dann wäre der menschen längst
gefressen von vermögen
wenn er nicht wäre wenn der wähler nicht
unmittelbar irgendwie auf die gefahr
reagieren
das kann man hier durchaus die katzen
bis entgegenhalten dass das
offensichtlich ja so eine reaktion ist
adrenalin und ins blut geschüttet wir
sind im überlebensmodus im kampfmodus
setzt das gehirn aus
ist natürlich interpretation aber ich
glaube schon dass dabei was dran ist
radikal sagt ideen und so weiter der
grund warum die karts tieren so was
nicht zugesteht
das war sozusagen der grund warum die
kartieren qualia nicht zugesteht und
warum mehr tiere als maschinen ansieht
ist einfach auch derweil einen sehr
anspruchsvollen journalistischen begriff
von empfindungen hat von einstellung
gegen die weite welt
das ist beides sehr sehr intellektuell
gefasst auch gedanken opposition ist
bewusst so weit
wenn er das etwas abschwächen würde dann
könnte er ohne probleme so was tier zu
sprechen
ich glaube da liegt schon ein wichtiger
punkt natürlich ist interpretation von
descartes aber er hat einfach ein sehr
anspruchsvollen begriff von klavier von
wie zu stellen die gehören seiner volk
seiner theorie zufolge als zen tiere das
fühlen zur disco getanzt und hat dann
letztendlich proposition gehalt ob das
wirklich der fall sein muss um zu etwas
zu fühlen sie frage
wie das
die katze
es ist
was andere bilden
was jedenfalls wichtig ist es dass
gedanken und auch gefühle nach descartes
sehr sehr rational gefasst werden weil
sie zur disco getanzt und der autor
interpretiert diese rationale struktur
so dass dadurch das sind tiere und so
weiter sind tiere heißt fühlen auf
lateinisch das sind tiere zu disco
getanzt der linken den substanz gezählt
wird
der grund dafür warum könnt ihr sagen
fühlen fühlen empfinden das hat nichts
mit rationalität zu tun
es wäre ja die gängige meinung wenn ich
etwas fühle etwas so erleide er leiden
sagt jetzt nicht etwas für etwas will
dann spüre ich in mir natürliche triebel
könnten wasser das schwöre ich dir sechs
tänzer im empfinden die ausgedehnte
substanz im körper spricht aber nicht
das denken und die karte zeigt aber sind
ihre empfinden gehört sowie tanz- und so
versucht jetzt der autor sind raus zu
machen also versucht zu fragen warum und
unter welchen bedingungen kann die karts
sind ihre in den bereich der asco gi
tanz einbeziehen und er bekommt daraus
über das ergebnis dass solche dinge wie
etwas wahrnehmen usw immer eine
proportionale strukturen das führt uns
auch zurück auf für die diskussion der
letzten sitzung
da hatten wir die frage aufgeworfen ob
erfahrung optimise wahrnehmen
begrifflich verfasst sein
die meisten naturwissenschaftlers sagen
natürlich erfahrung ist nicht
begrifflich verfassen aber viele
philosophen wie zb immanuel kant sagen
wahrnehmung letztendlich auch erfahrung
sind immer mit kategorien des verstandes
durchsetzt sind immer irgendwie
begrifflich durch vor
wir können immer wahrnehmungs urteil
fällen ich sehe dass das das ist dann
wieder auf dem niveau von descartes es
hängt also damit dass dann die wir
wahrnehmen fassen ob wahrnehmung als
wahrnehmung schon begrifflich
verarbeitet ist oder ob es nicht und mir
scheint in diesem fall des löwens eine
begriffliche verarbeitung eher
unwahrscheinlich zu sein einfach aus
diesem einfachen argument dass die
evolution wenn wir von ihr so sprechen
könnte von der evolution dass das
revolutionäre fall wäre wenn solche
dinge mit dem gehirn noch verbunden
wir müssen einfach den fluchten ganz
muss sofort in gang setzen wird dann
überleben das wäre so vermehren evidenz
gegen sind auffassung von künstlicher
verwoben
jedenfalls in diesem überleben zu müssen
es sind jetzt eigentlich schon am ende
ich lese noch ein zitat vor was gehört
sonst noch zu meiner wahrnehmung des
löwen und zu meiner furcht vor dem löwen
da werde etwas rein physisches die
physisches simulation meiner sinnesorgan
einige physiologische veränderungen herz
gehirn nerven drüsen und einem
vermeidungsverhalten zum beispiel
wegrennen aus die karts sicht wäre der
zusammenhang zwischen der sensorischen
stimulation und im verhalten vollkommen
mechanisch gezeigt den der wille bilde
einschreiten um das verhalten zufrieden
das war's für heute
wir werden in der nächsten sitzung
diesen text noch ein bisschen weiter
lesen werden aber auch auf den weiteren
text zu sprechen kommen dieser text will
ja nur anhand von descartes zu einer
these kommen die karte dient diesen text
nur als bezugspunkt die eigentliche
these haben wir jetzt noch nicht von
diesen text gelesen
das sollte jetzt aber nur mal geringer
sein wir lesen als in der nächsten
sitzung diesen text ein bisschen weiter
umgehen aber auf den nächsten sex über
um noch ein bisschen mehr in die
aktuelle debatte reinzukommen dann bis
zur nächsten setzen